In this video, we're
going to establish
a nice property of
the Poisson process.
Here is our setting.
We have a Poisson process
with arrival rate, lambda,
and so arrivals keep coming.
And we watch this process
until a certain random time, T.
So T is this time here.
Now, T is an exponential random
variable with some parameter,
and T is independent from
the Poisson arrival process.
What we're interested
in is the number
of arrivals that happened
during this time.
How can we answer this question?
There are two ways.
One is using mathematical
manipulations.
The other is using intuition.
Let's see what it
would take if we wanted
to solve the problem
using formulas.
So let's call N-T, with capital
T, the number of arrivals
until time T in our
Poisson process.
And we wish to find the
distribution of N-T. So we
want to calculate, for
example, the probability
that N-T is equal to
a specific number, k.
Now, we do not know very much
about this random variable,
but we do know the probability
of the random variable, N-T,
If we have a deterministic time.
So perhaps we can
condition by fixing
the value of the random
variable, capital T-- that
is, to condition on
that random variable,
taking on a specific value.
What happens in this case?
Well, if I tell you that
capital T is equal to little t,
this probability is going to
be the same as the probability
that N with little t is equal
to k, where N with little t
is the number of arrivals
until time, little t.
But the number of arrivals,
until a certain time,
is a Poisson random variable.
So we do know what
this probability is.
It is lambda to the k, e
to the [minus] lambda t,
divided by k factorial.
Now, if we have this
conditional probability, how can
we get the unconditional
probability?
This is done by using the
total probability theorem.
We consider all possible
values of little t, which
are all the numbers
from 0 to infinity.
We weigh each possible
value of little t
according to the corresponding
PDF of the random variable, T.
And we have this equality.
We know what this term is.
It is this expression.
And the density of
capital T, since it
is an exponential variable,
the density takes this form.
And so, in order to
find the distribution
of the random
variable, N capital T,
all that we need to do is
to calculate this integral.
But this is a rather
messy integral.
So let us try to
see if we can find
a shortcut to this problem.
So here is what we have.
We have a Poisson process.
Let's call it the
first Poisson process,
that has a certain rate, lambda.
And this Poisson process has
arrivals at various times.
And then we have a random
variable, capital T,
which is exponential.
How should we think about an
exponential random variable?
We can think of an
exponential random variable
as being the first arrival
in some Poisson process.
So let us put down a second
Poisson process with rate mu.
Since we have assumed
that capital T is
independent from the
red Poisson process,
we can just assume
that this blue Poisson
process is independent
from the first.
Now, let us merge
the two processes.
And we're going to form
a merged process that
records an arrival at
those times at which either
of the two processes
have an arrival.
This is the time of interest.
And the random variable
that we're interested in
is the number of red
arrivals until that time.
That random variable we call
N capital T. The discussion
will be a little simpler if we
define another random variable,
K, which is N capital T plus 1.
So K is the number of
arrivals in the merged process
until this time.
That is, we take those
arrivals of the red process,
and we also include
that arrival here.
So if the number of
arrivals that we got here
was N capital T, here we have
arrivals 1, 2, and so on.
And this is arrival number
K. So K is a random variable,
and we want to find what it is.
So what are we asking?
What is K?
K is the number of arrivals
in the merged process
until you get an arrival
in the merged process which
is coming from the blue process.
And now, here is how we can
think of this situation.
Think of each arrival in the
merged process as a trial.
Each one of these
arrivals is coming
either from the red process
or from the blue process.
Let us call it a success if it
comes from the blue process.
So in that case, K is
the number of trials
until we have a success.
K is the number of arrivals
in the merged process
until we have a
successful arrival,
meaning one that came
out of the blue process.
So what do we know
about those trials?
What are their
statistical properties?
First, what is the
probability of success?
The probability of
success is the probability
that when you get an arrival
in the merged process,
it is coming from
the blue process.
And as we have seen, given an
arrival in the merged process,
there is probability
that it's coming
from this particular
process that's
proportional to the arrival
rate of that particular process.
And it is equal, as
we have discussed
before, it is equal to this.
In addition, we have
discussed that when
you look at the merged
process, and you
ask, what was the
origin of that arrival,
and you ask, what was the
the answers to
these two questions
are independent of each other.
In other words, the
origin of this arrival
is statistically
independent from the origin
of that arrival.
So this means that these
trials are independent.
So what we're looking
at is a random variable,
which is the number of trials
until the first success,
in a sequence of
independent trials,
where each trial has
a success probability
equal to that value.
And we know what
that distribution is.
It is a geometric with
this particular parameter.
This gives us the
probability distribution
of the random variable, K, and
once you have the PMF of K,
you just shift it by
1 to the left in order
to get the probability
distribution, the PMF,
of the random
variable, N capital T.
And so this is the
answer to this problem.
The number of arrivals during an
exponentially distributed time
interval [has] a
geometric distribution
that's shifted by 1 to the left.